j'ai mis le mariole apostoli nous sommes
la risée de toutes les agences de
renseignement
il est temps d'entrer en scène mettez
vos messages me l'apprenez
bon c'est pas le choc recherche philémon
dans l'unique but de lui faire le vous
avez couru la nouvelle invention du
docteur bach terium la merci des essais
pour quoi faire tourner les serviettes
nom ds
j'attends c'est pour ça que vous êtes
ici pour en finir avec timmy pour devant
ce que c'est sous ce qui fait de votre
famille
c'est pourquoi sa part un gain samia b
verte allumé la télé mais comment s'est
passé à terre mais qu'est ce que vous
faites ça va pas jeudi à silo de dieu
en tambour à l'ol non
je ne veux pas moi de cette merde vous
aime public chéri
je déclare ouvert le festival des feux
d'artifice d'abord au programme à g qui
croit ces bruits le chef il a fait caca
finalement on va s'amuser casillas 2